Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David, P..
So yesterday, a guy from Alabama who said
he doesn't know a lot of Jews, he called in
and he wanted me to explain Yiddish words
to him.
And the questions were What is the what is
Schmeichel and what's the difference between
Schmeichel and shekel?
Now, the egg man called in, the egg man is
a Jewish man, and the Egg Man says it's wrong
that asking me Jewish questions is like asking
a black woman to touch her hair.
I don't know if this analogy is exactly right,
but let's listen to what the Egg Man had to
say.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave, the caller on today's
show was a schmuck without using any Yiddish
words, and I'm just kidding.
I really can't stand when people say to me,
Hey man, did you do this?
Hey, did you believe this?
That they've gone up to a black woman and
saying, Hey, can I touch your hair?
I mean, I get it like when I was in prison,
I mean, guys from the South that would say,
You're a Jew.
Where are you horns?
I get that.
But it's not 25 years ago.
And we have the internet in modern times now.
So I find it highly insulting.
And I go back to my original comment.
That caller was a schmuck for asking you to
speak for the Jewish language of the Hebrew
language or the Yiddish language.
Shalom brother.
Yeah, I don't
Speaker 1: know if I agree with the Egmond.
I mean, like, let's let's just think it through.
Would it be crazy to think, let's imagine
like a really spit?
What is a Mekel is is not exactly mainstream.
It's not like, Hey, do you do Jews believe
in the New Testament?
As like, now, OK?
So it's it's Schmeichel's.
It's pretty, pretty niche.
Let's say there was a discussion as to which
African countries were the main sources of
slaves brought to the United States.
And let's say in a conversation, someone said,
Oh, did?
Were there a lot of American slaves that came
from the Central African Republic, right?
That's a really specific question.
I don't know the answer to that.
Would it be wrong to wonder if a black person
in the group might be more informed about
that than I am?
I don't know.
I guess I'm not sure.
I don't think the eggman is right that asking
me about Yiddish words is the same as asking
to touch a black woman's hair, that there
just seems to be absolutely no comparison
there.
But is it reasonable to wonder whether based
on an individual's identity, you might know
more about a particular thing?
I mean, you if you knew someone was a parent,
I think it would be reasonable to go to them
with parenting questions over someone who's
not a parent.
If you knew someone was tall.
I don't think it's unreasonable to go to them
with questions about the day to day of living
while being tall.
I don't know.
I don't know that this is that that crazy.
I think the real critique is, you know about
Google, right?
Like if I ever wonder about these questions,
you just you just Google it.
I don't know that you need to leave me a voicemail.
Wait two weeks for me to get to that voicemail
and then give you an answer.
But it is content.
So I don't know.
Let me know your thoughts.
We have an explosive bonus show today.
There's not an emergency blowout the way that
Alex Jones described earlier on the show,
but we have a very explosive bonus show today.
A Trump appointed judge has said the CDC exceeded
its jurisdiction with the mask mandate on
planes, and the judge ended the mask mandate
on planes.
Yesterday, pilots came out during flights
and announced to their passengers.
The mask mandate is over.
They unmasked and passengers cheered and unmasked,
and immunocompromised people on those flights
were horrified.
We're going to talk about it.
Also, J.D.
Vance, who I at one point thought, Hey, this
is kind of like a reasonable Republican.
I was wrong.
J.D.
Vance, who is running for the Ohio Senate
seat, has been endorsed by failed former President
Donald Trump.
We will talk about J.D.
Vance.
And thirdly, Elizabeth Warren is now targeting
Nancy Pelosi in a bid to avoid midterm losses
for Democrats in November.
What I will explain all of it to you on today's
bonus show.
You can access the bonus show instantly by
becoming a member at join Packman dot com.
Absolute last thing.
It is finally that day.
It's almost like Christmas morning for our
Christian viewers or the fourth day of Hanukkah
for our Jewish year.
I always got the best gifts on the fourth
day.
That's why I was always excited about day
four.
It is the day of the David Pakman Show Town
Hall, the town hall will be live today, Tuesday,
April 19, 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time.
We will be streaming live on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel.
And if you'd like to call in, you can do so
through our Discord David Pakman dot com slash
discord if you're a member.
We will have a priority line for you, which
is very exciting and just another reason to
get yourself that membership at join Pacman.
I will see everybody on the bonus show today.
On the town hall tonight or otherwise, sadly,
tomorrow, on the next day.